we're back with the host of the good
dish daphne oz gayle simmons and jamika
pessoa and we're about to dig into this
delicious croissant bacon egg and cheese
bake um but first how are you guys
feeling about the show launch like how's
the vibes wow the vibe's amazing we get
to go to work with our friends every day
first of all
we get to eat amazing food and
experiment in the kitchen which i think
has been so much fun amazing and we get
to teach and learn all at the same time
so i mean we're doing that teach the
audience like it is just we give and
take and they give it back to us because
social media the audience can tell us
what they want to see so we can create
things like the dishes and it's like
we really connect with our audience
which is so amazing we are we're
definitely here to share some of our
chef wisdom but it's more than that it's
like what actually works what really
gets dinner on the table at night what
makes us feel good when we get in there
and makes us feel positive about like
this one area that we're going to have a
good time and if i'm any indication of
your viewers i was just so excited that
you're putting this show out there right
now it's what i need and i'm so glad
that you guys are here and that we
actually get to meet again
every day just hop over if you need
something cup of sugar i'll always feed
you full meal t-bone steak will hang
we'll just you know break up the merlot
we got it all over in our studio
everything what do you think
what what
we love it it is it's soft
pillowy
oh my gosh you guys this is incredible
thank you so much for bringing this here
today this is such a wonderful dish
and this is just a preview of what
they'll get on the good dish we cover
everything and amazing guests like
yourself i mean we have cook-offs we
have beauty segments we're talking
fashion it is everything that you need
in an hour everything all the delicious
and really julian we can't thank you
enough for just making us feel so
welcome yeah i love it well i was so
excited to bring you guys a little
casserole gail i did we brought you
something oh my gosh
what could it be it's heavy and it's
melting but that'll make it more
delicious
[Applause]
all right that is from our brownie show
we i mean from our waffle show we put
with 99 things in a waffle
brownie waffles ice cream sandwich you
turn them into it's like that kind of
stuff will blow your mind if there's
anything happier and more infectious
than a show with you three ladies i
don't know what is so thank you so much
for coming here today thank you daphne
and tanita the good dish air's weekdays
nationwide check your local listings
thank you so much you guys for choosing
to spend your time with us we make this
show for you so take it with you
[Music]